bonjour et merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rtl francs de l'heure quelle
est la situation actuelle en martinique
actuellement la situation on va dire
nous avons effectivement avec des
services de détail des autres services
de
pour mettre en place
mettant en place d'outils en madiran ou
l'instant rétablissement de la
circulation
rétablissement des différents services
accès aux différents services
comment s'est passée la grande opération
de démantèlement de tous les blocages de
ronds-points
alors vous imaginez bien que ça c'est
pas passé sur certains points ça a été
notre point effectivement il a fallu
malgré tout les deux des moyens que nous
avons à disposition cette façon à ce
qu'on puisse rétablir la circulation
rétablir l'ordre sur
d'accord et c'est dur à l'ouest il y a
des des piquets de grève en ont repris
depuis
alors il y a toujours effectivement à
l'entrée du port
le board de martinique un piquet de
grève qui est toujours présent
il laisse de temps en temps passé ils
filtrent les entrées et les sorties
malgré tout sur une bonne partie du
territoire on va dire que la circulation
était rétablie le calme est revenu
revient progressivement mal quand même
pas oublier que s'il ces tensions ont
généré énormément de stress généré une
eau trouble également dans notre vie et
on oublie également cailloux mort malgré
tout pendant
ces troubles un mort sur un barrage en
état a perdu la vie et une femme qui a
été agressée sexuellement et malgré tout
ce n'est pas la seule parce que vous
savez ce genre de chose se produit tant
à se dire ça habille totalement en émoi
la martinique ces deux faits et sans
oublier que les gendarmes et les
policiers ont essuyé beaucoup de tirs à
balles réelles ce qui ne va
certains droits doivent leur vie par les
moyens qui sont à leur disposition gilet
pare-balles casque lourd on parle de ce
média on a parlé de quelques petits
pandas sachez que si le retour de mes
collaborateurs et moi même étant
également présente c'est un jour sur ces
manifestations il ya eu plus de sentir
des fois par nuit donc nous sommes face
à une situation également qui donne une
nouvelle image de la martinique
les collaborateurs non d'une
zone il faut qu'on tue tout ça
maintenant dans le ton qu'on rétablisse
l'ordre la sécurité pour la population
de la simulation la vie humaine sur la
martinique
les négociations sont en cours
actuellement avec les institutions avec
les trévise nous espérons que ça ira qui
vont pouvoir mettre à plat les sept
points qu'ils ont
ils sont dans leurs revendications mais
qu'une ça c'est pour effectivement
par rapport à une situation un moment de
l'été nous savons très nous avons très
clairement que ati mouvement les choses
peuvent apprendre parce qu'il ya pas mal
de problèmes sur l'île et notamment le
problème lié à la sécurité et là nous
l'avons vous très clairement il ya
beaucoup d'armes qui circulent qui dit
armes dit également droite dit tout
trafic et là on
espère vraiment que la martinique ne va
pas sombrer donc ce qu'on voit ailleurs
et on désire vraiment pas ça c'est pour
ça que même l'armée avons des renforts
actuellement sur l'île nous aider à
rétablir l'ordre d'établir une vie
paisible mais il faut que nous ayons
dire en forme de passion des mots forts
de manière pérenne de façon à ce qu'on
puisse vraiment
trouvé ces armes qui circulent en masse
et rétablir une vraie sécurité sur la
matinée la fin de sa vie hier que les
renforts policiers qui ont été envoyées
1 depuis la métropole vont revenir dans
pas longtemps ils sont vous savez
pendant combien de temps devrait rester
sur nine
alors là pour l'instant ils sont là ce
sont des missions vous savez qu'ils sont
des factuel ça peut être 10 ou 15 jours
franchement nous savons très bien qu'il
y à un travail de fond à mener au
pouvoir
de la situation persiste
que ce sentiment de sécurité reviennent
et nous mêmes par sentiment il faut que
la sécurité revienne sur notre
territoire et on sait très bien que les
renforts que nous avons actuellement
permettre de rétablir au moment où nous
parlons une certaine sérénité mais il
faut que ça perdure dans le temps sinon
on va peut-être d'ici de 1 an deux ans
trois ans se retrouver dans la même
situation que nous avons connue avec
d'une part la problématique sociétale
que nous connaissons par rapport en
espérant que ça dure et ça ne continue
pas nous toucher mais il ya d'autres
problèmes la vie chère le couple
il ya des problèmes en martinique
notamment le clos des cols comme de
l'eau également sur la guadeloupe
île soeur même si effectivement des
problèmes n'arrivent pas forcément au
même moment mais nous avons des
problèmes qui sont là depuis très
longtemps et aujourd'hui la société
comme il ya quelques temps là explique
très clairement il faut absolument qu'il
y ait des gens qui se mettent autour
d'une table au pouvoir travailler autour
de ces problématiques et nous savons que
ces problèmes ne vont pas être résolu du
jour au lendemain donc à tout moment si
ça tarde trop on peut se retrouver dans
une configuration
mais malgré tout il faut quand même que
ces discussions se réalise avec autour
de la
sécurité et cette sécurité je le répète
même s'ils contiennent monde là une
sommes en train de rétablir
malgré tout il faut une police qui soit
qui des renforts une arme renforts
matériels de façon à ce qu'on puisse
les nice merci en tout cas d'avoir
répondu à nos questions rappelle que
vous êtes secrétaire
départemental unité sgp police fo
martinique merci à vous